Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go ahead and take a look at how to create
a cloth material and create materials with textures that have alpha information.
So let's get started.
In our scene in Unreal, on the last part of our lecture, you'll see that I have an object
in our 3D space here, in Unreal that actually has some alpha information in it.
I'm going to show you how to get this to be active, and some of the other options you
can do to be able to make this a cloth alpha object in which you get the settings for
a fuzz color and a cloth option.
Now each one of these gives you the ability to be able to change things a little bit,
but you don't necessarily have to use it, but the option is there.
We're going to talk a little bit of the difference between them.
You'll see that cloth is an input that enables you to control the strength of the fuzz color
as a mask.
The fuzz color, which you'll see in just a minute, this enables you to add color to
your material, to simulate shifts in color when light passes through.
Now again, you're simulating it, so it's not going to necessarily be 100% true, and also
you have to be careful these two can mute each other out.
I'll do an example as you can see it up close.
Let's go and take a look at this material.
Then we're going to go ahead and make a simplified version of this material.
We're going to go back and look at some of the dependencies this material may run into.
I'm going to go and click on this object in 3D space, and I'm going to go to my cloth
completed and double click on that.
We see that our material pops up.
We already have it active, but you can go in here and find the textures for cloth that
we have in place, and you can find some of the materials that we have active.
You can simply do that by hitting the magnifying glass, and you'll see under step four, it
says cloth sample.
Let's go ahead and look at this up close.
So to be able to make this material, I've selected the blend mode of masked.
This is used whenever we want to have alpha information to be read, and we can punch it
into our opacity mask.
But I've also added shading model cloth.
Now this is an option which gives you again that same fuzz color option as well as cloth
option.
Let's go to the slides for a moment, and we'll talk about this a little bit more in depth.
So the shading model cloth simulates a fuzz layer and will produce more realistic results
for cloth.
Now you do got to be careful because fuzz color and cloth can mute each other, so you
have to get the values just right.
So we're going to get a simplified version up close and compare it with this more complicated
version.
Again, the fuzz color, this input enables you to add color to your material to simulate
the shifts of color when light passes through it.
And cloth, although you know you're like wiser cloth note inside of cloth might seem a little
bit redundant, but this input enables you to control the strength of the fuzz.
It probably should be called fuzz color, but we left it as cloth and uses it as a mask
and value of zero indicates no fuzz color contribution to the base color, whereas a
value of one blends fully over the base color.
Now you can put color information in here if you wanted to, but primarily you're going
to probably want to use a scalar parameter to be able to get more out of it because it's
a very it's a very linear node.
Let's go and jump it back into Unreal and take a look at this up close.
So in our material, this is the one that's already in the scene.
I have things pretty set up, set up pretty simple.
And I'm just pulling color information into the fuzz color and fuzz cloth.
If I disconnect some of these, say we'll disconnect cloth, you'll notice that a whole lot happens,
right?
Because it's looking for a number value.
This is what I meant before, but we also have fuzz color.
So if we go down here and say we get fuzz color information and bring this up, we can now
punch this into our fuzz color.
And you'll see if we increase the strength a bit more, you'll see these values get a
little bit strong over the surface.
Now our cloth, remember when I said they depend on each other and they can mute each other
out.
Well, if I go in here, I could either put a scalar parameter like say I'm going to detach
this and bring this around.
I can punch it in here or put in a scalar parameter, just put the numbers in or just
do it this way.
And then you'll see the strength kind of shine through.
So this is what I meant that you got to kind of find a happy medium of what you want.
I'm going to set this to one and maybe even a point five, but you'll notice it is muted
in a little bit, but not maybe to the amount that we want.
That's when we have to go into the fuzz color and go in here and maybe lower this at least
half or at least down to maybe 10.
Then we can even go to like two and maybe even one.
Now this color is making it so that we're imitating a fuzz type of look.
So if you need to mute things even more, you can do it with the amount or just simply change
the color closer to your original object.
So if I move this a little more closer to blue and hit OK, you can see that it's a little
bit closer to what we have.
And it has kind of almost like a haze fuzz look on here as it relates to the light.
So it's almost like using kind of a Furnal Index type of approach to give us a simulated
fuzz look to our object.
Our fuzz color then can go in here and we can set this maybe 0.2, lower that, and you
can see now it's muting things a little more believable and the fact that we can see the
results a little bit clearer.
And we can go to maybe five if you wanted to.
All this we can use with a scalar parameter.
And the cloth primarily is going to be driven by numbers.
Now if we went in here and said, Hey, man, I'm going to go and put a color in here.
You'll notice that information is going to be kind of muting each other.
And this is what I meant by you probably just want to put some numbers in here because these
dependencies will influence each other.
And this is primarily being driven by numbers as it says in my notes.
Now if we look at a simplistic version, if I go to my content browser, we can go in here
and underneath our intro to materials, we're going to go and go to our in class material,
we're going to right click in here and make a new material.
I'll keep this pretty simplistic.
So I'm going to go M underscore cloth.
Got to be able to spell cloth.
That was class.
I think that's like Scottish for cloth.
So cloth sample.
And I'm going to double click on that.
So again, we're messing with blend mode and shading model.
Now you don't necessarily have to use the shading model.
Again that gives fuzz and cloth to be able to be accept accessible.
But I'm going to switch this mainly blend mode into our mask.
And that mask is now going to give us an opacity mask.
Now it doesn't open up opacity.
It does if we go to the previous material, you'll see we do have an opacity set in here
that controls a translucency of the material when substrate is enabled.
This actually can work with substrate as well.
So you have kind of like an alpha composite blend situation that you could use this if
you needed it.
But over here, we just need it because we simply just turn on mask.
We have our opacity mask active.
Now we can drive this with numbers or even try to drive it a little bit with a texture.
But for the most part, you're going to see some values on some of these by default.
But obviously just like rough and spec, you can put in a black and white kind of value
in there.
And we can do the same with some of those.
Now right now, again, we're just using simple mask.
And we just have an opacity mask set up and ready to go.
What I'm going to do now is go in here and go to my control, go to my content browser,
excuse me, and we're going to go ahead and get that cloth texture that we need.
Now this is where our cloth is at, but we need to go ahead and grab that rip cloth or materials
at we need to grab that texture.
So I'm just going to pull on these simple PNG that I have.
It has already has an alpha embedded.
So I'm going to pull in the RGB to the base color and then I'm going to grab that alpha
information and put it right into the opacity mask.
So I'm not driving numbers for this one.
I'm simply pulling in my health information to it.
Now you'll notice it's not rendering on both sides.
So when that happens, especially if you have a draped cloth or maybe your character has
a cape of some kind, you want to be able to see both sides.
So in that, let's click on the grid and in this material, we want to go to the details
and turn on two sided.
And that'll give it so that we have both sides to our cloth object.
In more advanced classes, we talk about how to actually have it so you can render two
different types of textures on either side of that.
But in this case, such as like with a leaf, but in this particular case, we just want
to keep it simple.
So you can get a little info on the introduction of this.
And you can see that we've made a simple masked object, our texture.
And then we open up the parameters in the material to be able to get that texture that
read make the material to be able to read that textures alpha information.
And we have it all set up pretty quickly.
In the lecture notes, I walk you through step by step how to mess with these and to plug
them into where you want them to be.
It's really up to you how you want to play and experiment with Unreal.
But we give you the tools to be able to you to be able to customize any look that you
want and feel as necessary for your game or linear content.
In the slides, you'll see a link to get more information on this.
And you'll find this also not only with 5.5, but 5.6 to get a breakdown of how to work
with these materials and textures and to get things in the right direction.
That's it with this lecture.
In the next video, we're going to do a little bit of a recap, talk about everything we've
looked at and wrap things up.
Thanks again.